دخلت المتهمه بتفجير شارع الاستقلال تركيا
بشكل غير قانوني قادمه من عفرين شمال
سوريا ووصلت الى منطقه السنوار اسطنبول
قبل اربعه اشهر من التفجير برفقه ثلاثه
اشخاص في الساعه الرابعه و13 يوم الاحد
وضعت حقيبه مليئه بالمتفجرات قرب احد
المقاعد في شارع الاستقلال بحسب السلطات
التركيه لتنفجر الحقيبه الساعه الرابعه و
20 دقيقه متسببه بمقتل سته اشخاص واصابه
81 اخرين بعد ذلك التقطت كاميرات مراقبه
صورا تظهر المشتبه فيها دون حقيبه وذلك في
ساحه تقسيم قديمه من شارع الاستقلال ثم
توجهت المتهمه الى منطقه اسرار التي تبعد
نحو ثلاثه وعشرين كيلومترا عن شارع
الاستقلال ثم الى منطقه التي تبعد نحو
ثمانيه وعشرين كم عن الاستقلال لتقتحم قوه
الامن مكان المتهمه في هذه المنازل فجر
الاثنين اذ كانت تستعد للتوجه الى الحدود
التركيه اليونانيه للتسلل الى الاراضي
اليونانيه وفقا للسلطات التركيه